Lexx asks Gary I've got a question for
you
who is the historical figure you would
have lunch with if you could and why Lex
great question first and foremost two
things one Lex I really think you should
put a URL in your Instagram account so
links out and to vaynernation you should
check out his Instagram
it is a tremendous tremendous effort
great pictures
I mean we're rolling with heavy truth in
episode 64 the answer to this question
is nobody and I really really really
hate giving it because if I'm on the
other side of this camera I'm looking at
that and saying you think you're so
great that there's nobody you want to
meet and weirdly there's probably a
truth to that it is actually
fundamentally completely insane how
little energy I have of meeting anybody
all time there's plenty people that I
find ridiculously fascinating you know
Winston Churchill is super high and
interesting Randy the Macho Man Savage
is a big one for me Pete Rozelle the
former NFL Commissioner I just read I
read his book I don't read a lot of
books I read a book when me and Lizzy
went away in November I'm up to nine you
know there's a million wall you know
Walt Disney's interesting storytelling
like there's people interesting but it's
crazy like if you said you could have
dinner with any historical figure we're
talking Abraham Lincoln Walt Disney or
the Jets could be you could be not
playing in the Super Bowl that's what
I'm going you could be in August right
now and watching the Jets first
preseason game I'd rather do the Jets
preseason game think about how insane
that is like preseason I said it's
there's something really broken with me
and I think it comes from ego DNA I do
or just speaks to like a theme that I
think a lot of you know which is I'm
like this right like I'm um I mean I you
know I'd rather look at Christine's
Twitter account for 19 minutes and bring
that value to the people that have
bestowed in me the interest and paying
attention to me then for me to go and
spend you know
a nice meal and drink some nice wine
with you know Joseph Stalin so I can
tell me this piece of crap I mean I
don't know like like I don't I don't I
don't uh I don't feel it I've never felt
it I have no interest it's just super
not interesting for me